reject nation thank you so much for
clicking on this video we are going to
watch a clip from marvel entertainment
called run for the movie eternals which
we're watching on monday probably put
out a video on tuesday giving some
thoughts feeling pressure to not spoil
anything or go specific because there's
a weird wiggle room for what you can and
cannot say before the embargo officially
lifts what's a review really let's see
what this clip is though
[Music]
is that icarus
huh
[Applause]
awesome
nice to see a speedster back in the mcu
montego
[Music]
ah
dude
there's going to be
that's right
that's my hey everyone in america is
going to be learning asl now's noise
yeah man yeah that was cool putting
center stage here for makari i mean in
the trailers for some reason it's her
power set moves that seem to be the ones
that stand out to me the most and i i
can't quite pinpoint exactly
why it is i love speedster action just
captured on camera i think it's really
cool it's always practical right
it's just shot different i don't know
how to put into words it feels visceral
it doesn't look like it's complimented
they're trying to like mask a lot of the
the fast movement with whatever
residual effects that occur whether that
be more motion from her or lightning or
something like that and yeah look at it
look at a freaking icarus being all
damn superman
yeah well i think i mean to me i think
the thing is you know with a lot of
their other powers that we've seen in
this trailer they're all kind of these
golden energy blasts to some degree or
else these weapons that they can form
again golden whereas makari's powers are
a bit more physical and visceral at
least since they're presented here in
this trailer and yeah like that motion
blur they give to her like i'm curious
to see how that effect goes throughout
the whole movie because i know we've
seen at least a couple other shots of
that in the previous trailer and that is
yeah an effect that i often am like
we're so close and it's so hard to make
it look natural but i feel like here it
very well could and yeah that could kind
of separate her and make her that much
more distinct from everybody but this is
a cool it was cool to see this action
moment breathe a little bit more because
i feel like we've seen little snippets
of it uh you know just cut up and diced
around in these trailers but this was
nice to at least get an impression of
how you know an actual action set-piece
scene might move around and breathe not
to say that this also isn't edited down
from what it might be in the movie but
it felt a lot more fluid and i think
chloe zhao it's interesting because even
though it is just an action scene she is
she's like a actor's director is that
the right way director's actor
director yeah that's why everybody
watching the characters here even though
it's an action scene you still get a
sense for the kind of performances they
are even in battle there's still a
performance there and they still got to
be in character when they're doing the
fight scenes so it is fascinating when
you're looking at richard madden's
icarus who does seem to embody i am god
like this whole time here but then you
cut to people like kingo and makari who
have their personalities still
showcasing and they still feel like
relatable
whereas icarus is like i am this
benevolent being yeah
exactly i'll say though like i'm a huge
male non-gianni fan and i i'm still
going i don't know how i'm gonna get
pulled out watching him because even
just in these little snippets i'm
constantly aware i'm watching camille
montreal granted it's just a clip and
we've only seen trailers so i can't
speak for how i'm gonna feel when
watching the actual movie just watching
camille nanjiani here doing some of the
energy blast i'm becoming aware of like
oh yeah see camille's moving pretty good
yeah okay that's camille maggiano what
was the choreography like well take this
seriously when he was doing like i'm so
joking around
so where's camille that i have a hard
time moving past that yeah
this will be the first time you know
like they made a huge deal on those
magazines and everything about like he
got ripped and you know this is the
first time you know he's this buff in
his life and everything and now this
will be also the first time we get to
see him move and perform as a buff
marvel bodied actor yeah so you know
it'll be a whole new experience of
camille not johnny i mean he fills out
the suit well the deviants do look
imposing they do look scary i hope
they're not just i don't know they're
big dogs
big dogs that look like they can get
their ass kicked pretty easily well
that's the thing about this clip is and
i'm curious because this is a scene that
seems like they're well within their
element and they're you know having fun
with each other it's not that big of a
threat they're taking care of business
it seems like and so this makes me
wonder okay what's the actual fight
where they are like oh god i don't know
if we're gonna win this one gonna look
like where they aren't you know on their
a-game and they aren't you know feeling
like they got this you know what would
be funny is if uh makari died just right
in that scene and what they did is they
cut right before one of the deviants
falls right on top of her yeah like the
suicide squad i mean what i was getting
at was that we've lost the speedster
already and then we thought we had a
speedster resurged with one division
and then uh now
i'm hoping this speedster actually gets
to stick around i don't think they'll
kill her i know but it would be funny
just to watch the backlash i know there
was a lot of jokes that were made about
how kevin feige was you know all all
astounded by the fact that they shot
this on location and and not in his
freaking green screen what is
so but you can feel that though here
like that does come to life and feels a
lot more palpable when you're watching
an action scene like this which is
relying still on cgi to fulfill the
action scenes i mean just along with the
deviants and the powers that they're
using but shooting it on location having
an actual landscape here just feels a
lot more believable i'm excited for this
i'm i'm hoping that this movie
truly definitely delivers
on being the greatest most oscar-worthy
mcu film of all time we'll have to sit
wait and see let's see how it goes it's
gonna be good
guys what you think about this clip are
you ready to run to the theaters
are you ready to
subscribe and click the notification
bell to hit the like button kill that
dog
and uh hey let's do a
adelia chamberlain you came to my mind
for several reasons on this video partly
because our love for you
is eternal and i feel like that's shared
right back at us with how long you've
been a supporter how long you've been
with us on patreon how long you've been
a friend of the real rejects and two i
mean all of these eternals they're all
talking about like oh man we've been
observing for so long never interfering
that's kind of like you with the
shmodown world observing for so long
watching all these different people do
their thing but now you are an active
participant you're disturbing the
balance you're causing a ruckus soon the
watcher is going to come down and be
like adelia what are you doing but for
right now i am glad that we have you and
i'm glad for your support and uh
i gotta accept your friend request on
facebook i think he sent me a friend
request on facebook so uh
we're taking it to a whole another level
love you delia
act like you know you don't even have a
request success
[Music]